eBay
okay let me take the bike first did you
hear the back row okay great
okay I'm Barbara Meade and one of the
founders of politics and prose and I
just wanted very very much to come in
and introduce Stephen Budiansky because
that I enjoyed this book so much it was
I just thought it was such an impressive
accomplishment that to write this book
to even had to delve deep into
mathematics linguistics engineering as
well as the technical history of code
making and code breaking from those
early electric calculating machines that
Alan Turing was instrumental about that
were used during the Second World War so
much of this is local history or at
least the Second World War part of it is
local part of it is local history
because at that time the NSA was right
here on Nebraska Avenue where NBC is and
it wasn't until 1957 that they moved out
to Fort Meade so in that long history of
technology that Stephen had to master he
started with those machines that were
manufactured by the National Cash
Register company in Toledo Ohio and then
so he moved on to digital computing
which is how code breaking is done today
and I have to add that also that he had
to become knowledgeable enough about
organizational behavior to understand
the behavior of the people mostly
talented individuals within the
organization of NSA who very often
behaved in a very dysfunctional way so
so it was a wide specter of knowledge
that he had to have
and out of that because some cells are
so much knowledge Publishers Weekly says
about his book Budiansky is lucid in
describing the science and art of
breaking complex eyesight of breaking
complex ciphers he Lovins the history
and technology with colorful profiles of
cryptographers and spies the result is a
lively account and engrossing history so
that's a a wonderful compliment for a
book that is so heavy in the subject
matter that you need to wade through but
it is true it is truly a lively account
steven has previously written seventeen
books ranging from such subject matters
as biography of the composer Charles
Ives to military history in history of
intelligence science Natural History and
that includes animals including lions
horses dogs and cats I tell them I just
ordered his book called the character of
cats he's widely versed as you can see
all this started back when Stephen
received his Bachelor of Science degree
from Yale and a Master of Science from
Harvard University he has been the
national security correspondent and
foreign editor of the US News and World
Report as well as editor of world war ii
magazine he was also the Washington
editor of nature magazine and has
written for The Atlantic Monthly The
Economist The Washington Post in the New
York Times
so I told Stephen right before we
started that besides enjoying his book
very much that one reason that I wanted
to introduce him was that when I was a
senior in college NSA was touring
college campuses
recruiting prospective employees and I
interviewed with NSA and to two weeks or
three weeks later I got a formal letter
from NSA offering me a job as a
beginning cryptographer I mulled that
over for probably about a month maybe a
little bit longer but then I turned them
down and accepted a job with National
Geographic instead so if I had kept if I
had taken that job I might have been in
Stevens books I might have been but none
of that came true so Steve is going to
tell us about the whole history of NSA
over this past well starting a pre-world
War two but it's a fascinating history
so here Steven to tell us about cold
warriors thank you thank you very much
for getting like oh okay okay you could
see the time I'll read all your messages
okay I wouldn't even have to yeah well
thank you so in in the branch of showbiz
that I'm in which is writing serious
books of history timing is of course
everything and in the wake of the
revelations of Edward Snowden which is
certainly focused unprecedented
attention on NSA this couldn't be a
better time to I think spring on the
book buying masses a serious account of
code breaking in the Cold War on the
other hand it probably couldn't have
been a worse time to try to research a
serious account of code breaking in the
Cold War back in 1999 when I wrote my
book battle of wits which was about code
breaking in world war two NSA was in the
midst of at the time an unprecedented
move toward openness releasing
historical documents and retired code
breakers who had worked on the Japanese
and
german codes in world war ii were
thrilled at being given the green light
for the first time to speak publicly of
their wartime exploits and we're even
allowed to go into considerable
technical detail about the scientific
story behind their remarkable
achievements but in the post snowden
world has NSA officials always denote
our present moments on earth i found
almost no one willing to say anything
about anything they did at NSA or its
predecessor agencies even during the
very first years of the Cold War some 70
years ago now to be sure relying on the
recollections and tales of participants
is always a risky business when it comes
to intelligence history I recently
reviewed for The Wall Street Journal Max
Hastings new book about secret
operations in world war ii and at the
start of his book AI he quotes the
cautionary words of Malcolm Muggeridge
who worked for the British secret
service during the war before going on
to a distinguished career as a man of
letters and British television
broadcaster Muggeridge said intelligence
work necessarily involves such cheating
lying and betraying that it has a
deleterious effect on the character I
never met anyone professionally engaged
in it who might you care to trust in any
capacity and Muggeridge went on to say
that the temptation to embroider and
exaggerate particularly goes with the
territory as he rather more acerbic li
put it writers of thrillers tend to
gravitate to the secret service as
surely as the mentally unstable becomes
psychiatrists or the impotent
pornographers my apologies to all the
spies psychiatrist and pornographers in
the audience but you know so given all
of this I thought for this book I'm
going to try to tell the story of this
more recent period of NSA's history as
much as I can just using the documentary
evidence that had been officially
Declassified and released combined only
with
my general understanding of codes and
code breaking and computing to help
piece together what is admittedly often
a very fragmentary public record there
is a lot out there now from the Cold War
period but as anyone who's worked with
classified and Declassified materials
knows it's a real through the
looking-glass experience to figure out
any rhyme or reason why some things get
released and other things remain
classified NSA for example still insists
on classifying as secret or top-secret
descriptions of Soviet cipher machines
that were last used in 1946 70 years ago
these devices had mechanical rotors that
turned like the Nazis World War 2 Enigma
machine if you own a cell phone you now
have in your pocket an encryption device
that is a quadrillion quadrillion
quadrillion quadrillion times more
powerful and more resistant to
deciphering than any of these antique
Soviet relics from the early Cold War
and even more interesting in the
meanwhile some considerably more
sophisticated soviet code machines from
the 70s and 80s have actually come on
the collectors market have been
purchased by private individuals have
been analyzed and described by academic
cryptologist in the open literature yet
NSA still treats their very existence as
secret information now again it's worth
emphasizing that these cold war-era
cipher machines are truly ancient
history in the technology and practice
of cryptology and i was talking to
someone at NSA once and i said do you
realize 70 years that's the same
interval of time that separates the end
of the American Civil War and the start
of World War two during which time a few
innovations such as electricity the
automobile the airplane and the radio
appeared and you know the last 70 years
have if anything brought about an even
more sweeping technological revolution
in computing and electronics okay
another example for the
longest time NSA stuck to a hard and
fast rule that while it might be okay to
talk about how we beat the Germans in
Japanese in World War two
it was absolutely forbidden to ever
breathe the hint that the US had ever
ever listened in on the communications
of a nation that it was not actually at
war with and this included even Vichy
France during World War two we couldn't
admit we were monitoring their
communications and even Japan before
World War two
I was very puzzled in the course of my
research for this book when I started
reading an NSA study on signals
intelligence during the Vietnam War that
was released not too long ago and I saw
that they had repeatedly cut out from
the Declassified version what were
apparently references to dates when
certain US intelligence gathering
operations began in Southeast Asia and I
was wondering what what what are these
dates and why did they cut this out well
a few years later in response to an
appeal that was filed by someone a less
expurgated version of the same document
was released and lo and behold it turned
out that NSA censors had gone through
the first time around and carefully
snipped out anything that might give
away the shocking and highly damaging
secret that the United States was
monitoring North Vietnamese
communications before the Year 1961
which was when the first US soldiers
actually set foot in the region now if
you've ever seen one of these expurgated
or so-called redacted declassified
documents it's a sight to behold they
used to have some guy in the
declassification office I think
literally armed with a big magic marker
who would go through and you know cross
out anything that was still being
classifiable and this of course resulted
in these very scary-looking pages with
these big blacked out things sometimes
the whole page would be completely black
and that you get but now thanks to the
wonders of modern technology they
produce these nice tasteful whited out
boxes with thin you know the pencil
rules around them but the result either
way is enough to drive a researcher to
distraction you know you keep thinking
oh I've got something great in my hands
and then
you find every other word has been
chopped out and it's like trying to
solve a crossword puzzle created by some
demented version of Will Shortz or
something it's and you know and for a
while I kept a collection of some of the
more wondrous redacted documents I had
received that there was one I don't have
it anymore exactly but it was something
there was this one sentence that read
something like blank cut out was the
most blank sources of blank during the
period blank to blank I thought okay
someone worked hard at this one but okay
nonetheless I had some small triumphs
sometimes the same document would be
reviewed for release by two different
agencies or even two people in the same
agency at slightly different times each
of whom had different ideas about which
sixty-five-year-old secret would imperil
our nation's security were to be
revealed so in one report from 1950 the
NSA reviewer cut out the locations of US
intercept stations that had been picking
up Soviet radar signals but left in the
radio frequencies they were operating on
but in another Declassified version of
the exact same document
another NSA reviewer this time cut out
the frequencies but left in the
locations and then there was one
historical study from which the d-class
office had carefully cut out most of the
entries from a table showing the numbers
of US and British crypt analysts working
on Russian codes from 1948 to 1949 but
they left uncensored an accompanying
statement in the text describing the
percentage increase of some of the
missing figures and this ended up
providing two equations in two variables
which I was very happy to be able to put
my junior high school algebra to you
solving for the unknown quantities well
all right let me speak a bit about what
I was able to find out from this Swiss
cheese collection of archival materials
following the great triumph of US and
British code breaking in World War two
it quickly became apparent that code
breaking and signals intelligence was
going to continue to be a crucially
important source in the emerging cold
war struggle against the Soviet Union
the paranoia internal security measures
sealed borders and extreme secrecy of
Soviet society made conventional
espionage extremely difficult if not
impossible even the most basic facts
about the Soviet government's
organization the country's economy and
the military were considered state
secrets under Stalin's regime in the
early years of the Cold War the CIA kept
optimistically dropping agents behind
the Iron Curtain and it would later be
learned that virtually 100 percent of
them were immediately captured shot or
played back as doubled agents against
the West the only thing you're proving
by parachuting agents into Soviet
controlled territory when US army
officials told the CI station chief in
Berlin is the law of gravity
well the Soviets development of their
atomic bomb in 1949 gave signals
intelligence and even greater urgency as
signals were almost the only plausible
source that could detect military
preparations within the Soviet Union
that might signal an imminent Soviet
nuclear attack the huge challenge the
u.s. code breakers faced in exploiting
this vital source was that in November
1948 the Soviets abruptly instituted a
sweeping coordinated change in all of
their military code systems and it was
such an unprecedented development that
Washington and London briefly feared
that this itself was an indication that
the Soviets were about to launch a
military attack on the West the new
Soviet code systems proved far more
challenging than anything the US and
British codebreakers had faced before
and indeed most of the high-level Soviet
codes would remain unbroken probably
until 1979 when supercomputers and
advanced mathematical research produced
what one NSA paper referred to as the
height of American Cryptologic success
in the Cold War around the time of the
Soviet invasion of Afghanistan
throughout the Cold War at roughly
five-year intervals
NSA brought in outside panels of leading
mathematical and scientific experts to
review the state of the Russian problem
and its possible solutions and these
evaluations are almost nothing but a
tale of woe and pessimism in 1958 a
panel headed by the vice president of
Bell Labs concluded that quote no
national strategy should be based on the
hope or expectation that we will be able
to read well the rest of the sentence
was redacted by NSA's declassification
czars but it was pretty obvious it was
referring to high-level Soviet encrypted
traffic at one point in the mid-1950s
NSA had 15 special-purpose computers
running non-stop for five years
searching through 1 million intercepted
Soviet messages that had been in
ciphered with the machine the u.s.
called albatross trying to find any flaw
that could be exploited and the project
ended in failure
now incidentally whatever NSA successes
or failures in breaking Soviet codes one
thing they unquestionably did and I'm
not saying this facetiously at all was
provide a huge stimulus to the u.s.
computer industry the first magnetic
drum memory the first magnetic core
memory the first high-speed tape drives
the first all transistor computer the
first computer workstation the first
desktop computer the first high-speed
modems and the first supercomputers were
all built to meet NSA contracts and
requirements and only later made their
way to the commercial market
now one other consequence of this great
difficulty in breaking Soviet codes
though was a reinforcement of NSA's
institutional belief that amassing sheer
quantities of data could make up for a
multitude of failings elsewhere and this
is a credo we've certainly seen in
action in the recent controversies over
NSA's bulk telephone and Internet data
collection efforts now this belief in
trying to get everything goes back even
to the pre NSA days it was really
striking to come to me to come across
memos written in 1943 in the midst of
world war ii by the US Army and Navy
officials
charge of NSA's predecessor agencies and
they were arguing that their job
literally was to get everything to come
as close as humanly possible as one
official put it to collecting every
signal transmitted by all those
associated with us and against us well
this frequently led to NSA simply being
overwhelmed with more intercepts than it
could receive and even physically store
much less analyze even as early as 1955
NSA was receiving 37 tons of paper
printouts a month from intercept
stations around the world along with 30
million words a month more urgent
traffic that was sent directly by radio
teletype it was not unusual for NSA's
machine section to punch a million IBM
punch cards a month on just a single
problem and NSA was rescinding a
receiving 70% of all coded message
traffic going into or out of Washington
yet on occasions quantity could indeed
make up for quality in the aftermath of
these 1948 Soviet changes that I
mentioned that shut off the u.s. ability
to break high-level Soviet codes a huge
effort was put in by NSA to go through
plain language unencoded cables sent on
the Soviets internal radio Telegraph
networks now this was a real needle in
the haystack effort by the early 50s NSA
was processing 1.3 million of these
messages a month and of course as you
can imagine most of them just dealt with
incredibly mundane things yet by piecing
together details about railcar loadings
coal supplies lists of bank accounts
linked to various state industries NSA's
analysts working on these plain-language
cables were able to establish the
locations of major arms factories in the
Soviet Union produce basic statistics on
Soviet steel chemical and oil production
available nowhere else at the time and
for years this source provided the only
reliable information on the Soviet
atomic weapons program and the only
reliable set of warning indicators that
could signal Soviet mobilizations for
full-scale war and later reading of
plain language transmissions and other
types of signals intelligence that did
not depend on code breaking such as
Direction finding fixes on radars or
even just looking at the patterns of
transmissions without even knowing what
they actually said these techniques
would allow NSA to offer accurate
intelligence about China's imminent
intervention in the Korean War the
Soviet invasion of Hungary in 1956 and
the crucial information during the Cuban
Missile Crisis that Soviet traders had
in fact received orders from Moscow to
stop heading towards Cuba and not
challenge President Kennedy's naval
blockade of the island so even without
the long hopes for breakthrough against
Soviet codes by the mid-1960s something
like 80% of US intelligence about the
Soviet Union was coming from NSA and
signals now during the Cold War a
fundamental change was occurring in the
nature of electronic spying in another
way it was becoming increasingly the
case that crypt analysis in general as
practiced in the golden era of code
breaking back in World War two was being
superseded by what old timey code
breakers used to call second-story crypt
analysis that is breaking into an
embassy and just stealing code materials
or planting bugs and by the 70s and 80s
it's quite clear from the the
documentary evidence and that bugging
was becoming a primary focus of both the
US and the Soviets signals intelligence
effort in fact it was such a growth
industry for the u.s. that the CIA and
NSA both tried to claim the jobs for
themselves resulting in a monumental
turf battle and it was finally resolved
when Bobby Inman became NSA director in
1980 and negotiated what came to be
known as the peace treaty between the
two agencies Inman I should mention was
one of the few direct participants in
these events whom I was able to
interview and he told me about this
episode and and he said he went on to
explain that even after the peace treaty
had been negotiated there
still some problems to be worked out but
for a brief period during the spring of
1981 Inman was serving both as NSA
director and as acting CIA director so
he just sent memos back and forth to
himself approving his solutions never
had the two agencies worked so well
together he told me well one of the most
important consequences of the late Cold
War successes both the Soviets and the
US had in bugging each other's
communications was that it actually
produced a kind of ironic transparency
it offered both sides regular
reassurance during moments of tension
that the other side was not about to
launch a full-scale war and one former
KGB officer later said that the Soviets
bugging of official phones in Washington
in the in this period actually worked to
limit the natural predisposition of the
KGB toward conspiratorial
interpretations of US policy which is an
interesting moral to the whole story
back at the very end of World War two
one of the leading British codebreakers
at Bletchley Park wrote a long and very
interesting analysis I found in the
British archives of the setting out
what's going to be the future of
communications intelligence in the
post-war world and he began by putting
forth the rather counterintuitive
proposition he said that an
international agreement abolishing all
code and cipher communications would
contribute more to a permanent peace
than any other measure this is probably
a council of perfection he had it yet in
fighting the code Wars - a virtual draw
by the end of the Cold War the US and
the Soviet Union I think found a germ of
truth in that idealistic vision well an
ironic note as I suppose always a good
place to end on so I thank you all very
much for coming and I'd be delighted to
try to answer your questions thank you
one one night here because we have a
camera over here if people with
questions could please go to the mic
I had a chance to look through your book
before you started and you went into
some detail about the walkers and about
Ronald Pelton but nothing about polish
can I ask why
well my focus is on the Soviet Union
that was why
so was on the US versus the Soviets and
so that but they were all threes okay
yeah I see yeah yeah Pollard was spying
for Israel after all right okay
repainted okay sure icky day by study
begun to me uh and haha well consider he
played bastard
oh the question was about what was
considered secret under Stalin's regime
it was even the most I can't remember my
exact words but even the most basic
statistics about economic production the
organization of the government the names
and locations of ministries the names of
officials all of this was a literally a
state secret
and uh this effort of by NSA of reading
plain language
unencoded telegrams which we were able
to intercept provided an enormous amount
of this kind of very basic information
about what was happening the location of
arms industries locations of military
facilities and the whole Soviet atomic
program most of what we knew at that
time came from signals intelligence
which meant these unencoded telegrams
and it was a matter of piecing together
tiny things during those necessarily go
ahead during the negotiations for the
salt and start treaties one of the big
things that was able to be a
breakthrough was the use of national
technical means which is generally
considered to be like geospatial and
imagery intelligence in your research
did you come across anything that would
be
eeee comparable to that that was used as
far as signals intelligence as opposed
to overhead imagery well you know a
couple of points there there was a huge
effort to you collect telemetry data
about Soviet missile launches and arm
there was a guy at the last NSA history
conference a couple of years ago who had
worked on this and described he said the
Soviets often tried to hide
the signals by putting them very close
to television channels and it was
describing the challenge of this so I
mean this was clearly a very major part
of NSA's efforts at the time and
eventually we had geostationary
satellites that were collecting signals
being parked right over these bases and
Kazakhstan where this was going on
um I there was one reference to the fact
that we were able to learn um I can't
remember I think it's in the book
somewhere I'm sorry I can't remember the
detail offhand but that Kissinger was
able to obtain some important
information on the Soviets plan
negotiating position on the salt
treaties which were quite significant in
in the final negotiations
most of your book I guess was about
Russia do you have any feelings about
certain events like to South Africa an
atomic bomb explosion was a Indian or
the Pakistani and I didn't go into today
anyone ever admit to that do they is
that stall still classified they have we
don't listen to our friends yeah no I'm
sorry I I wish I'd do something about
that but that was not in the in the
sphere of what I was researching I have
a question it continued just like thank
you
my question is out of the anything new
about the big internet providers did
they use their information as well oh
man you know I stopped around 1989 in my
book almost deliberately so I wouldn't
have to engage the current controversy
which are extraordinarily complex and I
be the first to say they're
extraordinarily complex technically they
raise a lot of incredibly complex legal
and business questions and I'm just
going to have to punt on that one I'm
afraid but I know there are many people
more qualified than I am to discuss the
current controversies over the NSA's and
the Internet traffic
okay well thank you I hope it fold up
the chairs please and lean them against
something solid if you line up to my
left
Jesus will sit up here and sign copies
of this book
thanks for coming and thank you for
coming hello Rene did you get the copy
and sent you yes okay I know all right
but I just want to make sure I was
working out so I'm sort of still being
deep you dated or something telophase
security